the male's of the household are teaming
up jason sudeikis jokes he and his
one-year-old son Otis have some
surprises in store for fiance Olivia
Wilde on Mother's Day are you and baby
planning he's got all sorts of stuff
hooked up I you know but he won't let me
know because he doesn't know enough
words yet the 40-year old actor
ironically stars in the upcoming movie
Mother's Day where he plays a single
father raising young girls juice eggs
eggs and tampons oh yeah
10 bucks I'm just right t know what that
means he spoke with Jason at the
premiere for his latest movie the devil
and the deep blue sea a dark roll where
his character loses his expectant wife
he reveals he managed to separate his
personal life from the film thanks to
visits from wild and their little boys I
mean it's easy said they were there at
least for the two of the six weeks oh so
it's a good reminder yeah you you know
I'm not playing me I'm playing Henry so
so you know he just sort of try to I
didn't I didn't need to use only that to
sort of understand what he was going
through